منذ انطلاق الحمله العسكريه الروسيه لم
تشهد مناطق الشرق الاكرانيه هكذا تصعيد
القصف المتبادل بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه وصل ذروته ما دفع بقائم اعمال
رئيس الجمهوريه دونيتك الانفصاليه الى
تعليق العمل والطلب من مواطن مدينه دونيت
لعدم الخروج وبحسب السلطات المحليه
للمدينه كان لافتا ان صواريخ الاوكرانيه
تسقط بالاسواق الشعبيه وتدمر المرافق
المدنيه ما يشير الى ان القصف عشوائيه
كحيلنا يتركزوا القصف الروسيه على المناطق
المحيطه بدنيت مثل ماريكا وافديفكا اما في
مدينه باخوذ فما زالت قوات بادنر الروسيه
تطوق المدينه من الناحيتين الجنوبيه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الغربيه في محاوله
للدخول الى باخ موت وواسطه دفاعا شرسا من
قبل الجيش الاخراني
[موسيقى]